c'est non
les chroniques de la haine ordinaire
[Musique]
obama
abraham bavarois
j'ai honte
j'ai vraiment
je ne réponds pratiquement jamais
volumineux courrier que suscitent ses
chroniques
pourtant je pourrais profiter des rares
loisirs que me laisse mes diverses
occupations actuelles pour remercier
monsieur le goff de bagneux monsieur en
zac de saint denis dame des portes de
paris monsieur rivet danger monsieur
chazelas de changer les tout entre
autres
mais je ne le fais pas
je sais pas pourquoi
je préfère aller jouer au golf
ou mettre du vin en bouteille et
utiliser les timbres que m'envoie à ces
braves gens pour répondre à madame le
tercier deux camps monsieur cohen de
tulle où monsieur lefebvre de valence
lesquels m'adresse des lettres d'injures
mais sans joindre de timbres pour la
réponse
il ya par exemple je me suis servi du
timbre de monsieur barney de lyon qui
s'extasiait a servilement d'ailleurs sur
ma générosité de coeur pour répondre toi
même à monsieur jean-yves la rade de
nantes qui m'avait traité de fumier
alors il ya des invectives qu'on ne
saurait laisser glisser
cela dit quand j'entrevois la
possibilité de greffer mon imagination
vacillante sur une bonne idée d'un
auditeur j'aurais convenait en tort de
me gêner
tenez voici ce que j'ai reçu de monsieur
portal 2 valve cher chroniqueur de
l'amour exceptionnel six mois nous
sommes un groupe d'amis adhérents de la
1r e entre parenthèses association pour
l'éveil à la responsabilité à l'école
qui regroupe 250 personnes en france
par an + enseignants
pour jouer parce que nous aimons notre
pays nous proposons de nouvelles paroles
pour la marseillaise car si les
républicains est indigne que les soldats
y mugissent la raison le mec nous venons
d'adresser à rené monory et jean pierre
chevènement dans un but de cohabitation
descente les paroles qui suivent
s'ils veulent s'ils peuvent si ça vaut
le coup ils savent alors voilà les
paroles de monsieur portal et de sa
bande des 15
les deux sens à gaouaoui 250 de la 1r e
allons enfants de la patrie le jour de
gloire est arrivé liberté liberté chérie
ton soleil enfin s'est levé comme poum
entendez-vous dans les campagnes
retentir ses joyeuses éclats ce sont les
risées les vivats de nos fils et de nos
compagnes refrain au travail citoyen
traçons notre sillon courage à l'anc un
air plus pur emplissent nos poumons pont
pour bon
vous admirez me dit monsieur portal
l'économie générale du texte et
pardonnerez vous peut-être l'écologie
facile et le sexisme l'attend il vend
m'obséder
démilitariser les hymnes nationaux ça
c'est une bonne idée il est tout de même
inouï de constater que dans tous les
pays du monde où ce sont les civils qui
font le pain les maisons les outils et
les chansons les fêtes nationales et
leur hymne de glorieux sont au mieux des
apologies de l'engeance kaki parasitaire
ou au pire des appels hurleurs au
meurtre guerrier à l'instar de monsieur
portal et si les ministères concernés
m'avez fait l'honneur de solliciter mon
avis quant aux paroles de la
marseillaise jce depuis longtemps
déploré que les soldats mgi sas et
préconiser vivement que les objecteurs
hercules à ce que les bergères if he de
nas et que les troubadours si con plus
et puis d'abord pourquoi un seul hymne
pour tout le monde
pourquoi pas une marseillaise à la carte
pour chaque corps de métier pour chaque
minorité pour chaque français nom de
dieu
pourquoi moi par exemple moi qui suis
obsédé gérant ofi la tendance maniaque
hygiénique
pourquoi n'aurais-je pas mon hymne
national mais marseillaise que j'ai
chanterai debout à tous les coups si
j'ose dire
j'ai déjà un projet de parole
j'ai déjà un projet de parole vous
voulez que je vous le chanterai oui bon
alors maintenant chers auditeurs vous et
d'assister à un massacre parce que le
public du studio 109 nous enregistrons
cette émission va m'aider à chanter ça
va être horrible alors passez vite sur
rtl se gagne pas ça les mauvais français
barré vous sur europe
1 2 3 allons au fond d'la
gâteries le jour de foire est
arrivé les gens blancs entre nous faut
que je tire ma fille il ya un motard
tremblante qu'elle levait
damodar tremblant qu'elle rit faux pas
des goûts quand les balles
juillet et forest et sous la leaf jens
et jusque dans nos bras
pour dégorger novice à la campagne oh ça
mais c'est très bien
fort lettres l'oisillon
lâchement lâche mon
caleçon gains pur
j'accroche de tension
[Applaudissements]
comme ça c'est fait
je les dis
c'est pas pour gaffe tu es mais ça
m'étonnerait qu'ils en viennent
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est non non